today's episode is brought to you by
magic mind
magic mind flow state
now comes in a bottle if you're tired of
coffee
you want to do something different you
want to turn the corner
magic mind it is the organic version of
five hour energy
give it a try magic mine dot co
use promo code theo for 10 off today's
guest
is one of the um establishers of the
good fight foundation
uh he has a fight coming up against
conor mcgregor on
january 23rd he's the pride of louisiana
and um and he's the pride of many people
it is
my friend mr dustin the diamond juarez
[Music]
[Applause]
just
is it interesting kind of because you
turn it more into a
[Music]
i mean i get it's a celebrity but it's
more like a public figure like what is
it i mean it's
it starts there's something else that
happens outside of fighting yeah as you
as your
popularity get bigger you're not doing
it but it happens to you yeah yeah
you just find yourself in that position
somehow right yeah and i'm happy for it
too because
i'm busy all the time before it would
just be fights
then downtime and then hope to get a
fight again start training camp now it's
like
i have stuff planned as soon as this
fight's over i have other things going
on and
it's good busy is good but like i said
it's just i'm so thin my mind is always
thinking about something non-stop
that's crazy yeah i don't like the other
day i was driving i'm like who the [ __ ]
even is this guy anymore
yeah damn [ __ ] well then i guess i
don't know
i got i don't know if i can uh hit up my
booking and take my money off of dustin
for it or not dude but if you swipe up
now
matt will match your first deposit
though what's your code
dustin i might have to get in and wager
on it
um dude it's pretty crazy to think that
two white guys are now going to the
middle east to fight each other it's
pretty crazy you know yeah
right um very white
what did y'all do for new year's man new
year's we actually got a hotel
room down here in deerfield beach okay
and uh
it's probably about 10 minutes from my
condo just to break it up you know i've
been here since um
let me think
big beginning of november
so training camp just training going to
the back to my condo going to the gym
back to my condo it's just i needed to
break it up and okay
i thought new years was a good idea to
just get a hotel room get out of my
condo
and uh take a morning off did you it was
you and your wife did you go with the
kiddo
yeah i mean my wife and my daughter oh
nice now and this is personal enough to
answer it and uh
but do you is there like a do you put a
stop on the intimacy of y'all's
relationship if you're heading into a
fight like do you fight
i hear that about fighters i've always
heard that about boxing and stuff they
say it takes your legs away or or
whatnot but dude i've
i've came and knocked people out and
i've not came and knocked people out too
so
i don't really believe in it damn damn
i wonder if i'd rather have a guy who's
already recently
ejaculated yeah knock me out or a guy
that's full of knock me out you know
yeah i guess they're all different yeah
i don't feel it i don't i don't believe
in the and it takes your legs away i
don't think you don't know
i don't think wow see that's never
really been a thing in your head where
you're like okay
when i was younger i used to i used to
you did yeah dude i was watching
fightville and if you uh
if you want to get amped up for anything
if you want to end up spray painting a
building if you want to fight somebody
whatever you want to do arson
if you go watch fight field dude you
will be freaking pumped for it
um when you watch that do you still
relate to that
to that dustin poirier like it's you're
getting you're growing up
yeah the last time i watched it was a
few years ago but just sitting there why
i feel like it feels like such a
long time ago and i'm such a different
person and
go about fighting and and the thoughts
of preparing for a fight so much
different than
man it really feels like a different
world when i'm watching it i know it's
me i'm watching i remember going through
all the
things in the videos but it's just so
different man so
dude they shot it so well yeah it took
forever to shoot really
it probably took three years to shoot
wow and they have so much fights and
footage they don't even didn't even make
it to it
the problem was um the guy who was
filming it lived in new york with his
family and he would just come down
periodically whenever he saw a time in
in his schedule to shoot
and he'd come down for three months here
a month here so it took a really long
time to film the whole thing
damn yeah yeah they shot it i was
looking they shot it through the cage
almost as if they were watching animals
a lot of times like in some way you
don't understand
the way it looked like yeah very uh
yeah like you said like animals tribal
very tribal yeah just had like a
i felt like i was watching uh you know
like i remember at lsu they used to have
those videos on mike the tiger all the
time they'd shoot him just kind of going
through the cage you know or doing
something
yeah and uh it just reminded me of that
but and r.i.p to the to the lion i'm
sorry the tiger at the truck stop right
there
oh yeah oh yeah did he die again dude i
i mean one time i think is his
limit but that's true wow cats have nine
lives maybe you're right that's true but
louisiana
they got a camel there did you hear
about this yeah you know what truck stop
i'm talking about tiger truck stop right
right off the uh
the basin bridge oh i don't even know if
i've been there
yeah dude on the chaffalaia bridge right
between baton rouge and lafayette yeah
they had the tiger truck stop
and they had a real tiger there yeah and
a camel took his job yeah oh
yeah unbelievable but the camera
recently bit somebody oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah well that's a
louisiana camera bruh
dude because i think they they made the
camel quit smoking cigarettes right
right he's having some withdrawals um
dude when you watch uh what's going to
be different you think like heading into
this fight what do you think could be
different about it
dude every fight is different whether
it's the same opponent like this is a
rematch or
a completely guy a different guy never
fought before every fight's so different
because i'm in a different place in my
life
and my you know life's different every
fight so
just trying to learn and uh
be smart moving forward you know not
just in fighting but in life just
trying to move with with strategy and
not emotion man and that's that's the
that's my goal you know so you feel that
for like in the ring and out of the ring
yeah yeah yeah and in preparation
for the fight not you know if i feel
like i'm redlining a little bit my
body's run down i'll pull back a little
bit
and and rest up and just more about
quality than quantity at this point in
my career
i still feel young and feel great but uh
i would just
my goal is to stay in love with what i
do and i feel like sometimes
i can overwork myself or put so much
into it mentally that i start to hate it
and i don't want that that's a fine line
i got to walk right yeah because i've
been doing this a long time
yeah i can imagine especially this past
year because there was a couple times
you were gonna fight
yeah and it got pulled back um did you
come and start a training camp at one
point and then
have to call it off yeah i think two
times that happened the tony ferguson
fight we were supposed to fight in abu
dhabi
and then uh that kind of fell apart i'm
trying to think of the other one i think
there was two times i came
thinking that i was probably going to
get a fight and ended up going home damn
yeah
but i mean it's not done in vain because
i come here i get pushed i learn new
things with these guys you know
surrounded by a bunch of great
professional fighters and uh coaches so
it's nothing lost coming and doing that
it's just the middle
you know wrap some revenue engine up and
then not not getting a raise yeah
just um when you uh when you look at
whatever you did to prepare the first
time you fought conor
to what you do to prepare for to fight
for him this time is there anything
different like what's kind of i mean i
know you're a different person and i
know every fight is different you're
taking the fight at a different point in
your life so
you know who you are and what you're
even going to be doing is evolved and is
you know is coming in with a different
template but is there anything
like kind of specifically that you guys
are trying to do
you know just uh let my skills and and
work ethic and fighting do the job
you know of course the mental plays a
huge part in it but just not getting
tangled up in the in the
the mental aspect of trying to hurt this
guy or
this isn't about payback it's not a
revenge fight for me of course
of course those things are great you
know i go out there and beat him those
are all part of this storyline and all
of things that i'm gonna think about and
be happy with but that's not the driving
force
of each day um i'm driven by the main
goal of becoming the world champion
to being the best and i know that a win
over a guy like this at the point of our
careers it etches my name
in the history books on its own page i'm
in the books
yeah i mean honorable mentions right now
yeah yeah yeah you know that back page
yeah that theosaurus page whatever yeah
i'm under that i'm in there somewhere
i'm trying to get my own my own numbered
page here and i think a win over this
guy does that it submits me as
a legitimate combat sports professional
in a time that that's full of great
athletes you know connor khabib um in
mixed martial arts
oh yeah and uh you know him fighting
floyd it's just so much
history involved in this fight the full
circle
fighting him again now becoming an
interim champ switching weight class
just so much going into this that
i know what a win does for not only me
and my legacy but for my family
their future financially i know i know
what comes with the win and i'm ready
my i'm ready to bear that weight now at
this point in my career man
do you feel like um have you guys had
any communication
uh me and connor yeah we uh spoke on
social media kind of
got this fight started up we were gonna
do like a during the pandemic
nothing was happening and we were gonna
do like a charity right i remember that
event that was real he wanted to put
that on in ireland
and uh of course if it was possible i
was gonna do it and that just kind of
came out of the blue kind of i mean i'm
not sure how
how it came maybe i tweeted him or he
tweeted me something and then we kind of
went back and forth and
that's and then boom it was there
because that was because i remember you
and i were talking after the tony like
the tony thing was gonna happen
that they could never get the they never
got offered you guys the right money
it kind of was back and forth and then
and then it went away yeah and it was
that feeling of like now like kind of
now what do i do
and then this i mean this came along it
was almost like
not like a blessing because i mean it's
a fight you know but it's like
it was almost like the most perfect
scenario it's the biggest fight
besides the title fight and mixed
martial arts you can get
a fight with conor mcgregor yeah maybe
even combat sports
if you if if mayweather's retired or
what's going on but i mean
those two guys in combat sports right
now are probably the biggest opponents
you could be standing across
the battlefield from so to get a fight
of that magnitude i was excited when it
came together
um and i know what like i said what it
brings a win over connor
brings a lot more exposure and it brings
a title shot
do you think like uh do you have any
like keys going into the fight like um
if we get
to this far then i have this better
chance or i'm you know
that i have this different strategy i
mean i know for some of you might not
want to share but
like going into it is there just
something
because the first fight just ended in
the first round you know and i'm sure
that feels just so deflating because you
like you never real
you guys were just kind of getting into
the dance yeah i didn't even get to
fight you know the fight didn't even get
to blossom you know i uh
but that's fighting anything can happen
under those lights
i um i i want if you talk about game
plan what i want is for us to
to both be dripping blood and hurting
and suffering early in the fight
then we can find out who's the real
fighter you know that's what i want i
want to be bleeding
with a minute off the first round clock
i want this boat to be bleeding and
really have to dig down and see who's
the better fighter see who really wants
to be in there
you know because i don't have a safety
net this is i want to be in there yeah
and i know that
i know that and uh i'd like to find out
if he does
damn [ __ ] and and i don't and i
that's uncomfortable you know yeah
i'm not looking forward to getting
busted open but if we can get the fight
to that point to both of us are tired
and bleeding
then we can see who has more grit and
who has more want and i think i win that
fight 10 out of 10 times
dang bro damn yeah you're one of those
psychos bro i'm not sorry no offense
you're right here but
you're one of those guys that like you
like to go it's almost like you're like
one of those guys that like repels like
a spelunker
you like to just rappel into the depths
of your own freaking
darkness man and just and [ __ ] see
what's in there bruh
yeah yeah sticky things back in the day
you throw them on the wall and they were
kind of like
climb down the wall yeah you know yeah
like that into the depths of hell
yeah no i i i no but i think you've
always said you learned something about
yourself there i mean you told me one
time that you
like eve in a fight win or lose that you
there's something that coming out of the
other side of a fight that you're just a
different person
yeah yeah it's like a spiritual
pushing yourself and going out there and
i can't it's hard to explain but
coming out and going through the fire
you're a little bit different
um every time i feel
do you um connor's like a celebrity you
know conor is like i mean he's like the
billy elliot of ireland basically and
do you is it different fighting like a
celebrity do you feel like like is there
any added
thing to it does it feel different than
fighting just a fighter
maybe on the lead up to it there's a lot
more cameras around this training camp
there's a lot more
interview requests and media requests
and all kinds of things like that but
other than that
the actual fighting part is the fight
you know none of that comes in there
with you
so i don't think it's going to be any
different when the cage locks and the
bell rings it's going to be a scrap
you know and at this point in my career
all the extra stuff like i've been doing
this long enough and done so many
interviews and videos and it's not a big
deal anymore i don't enjoy doing it all
i like to train i don't want the camera
there when i'm in training camp but it
was there a lot this time but
i think this is my sixth main event in a
row so
all these past events have been full of
media as well so it's just kind of
the normal i guess dude i don't want the
camera there
they had the camera there today when i
was training here at this gym man and it
was
yeah you know might have to run a
wheelchair man it was
got a little rocky at the end um
do you feel like when you think back to
your first fight with connor and uh
and if you and if i'm bugging you
talking about just let me know do
nothing's off the table i'm i'm
i'm comfortable because it's fascinating
with anything i feel fascinated i get to
talk to somebody who's about to go like
fight in like the craze like the fight
like there's a lot of people fighting
like after school next month like that
this month that nobody gives a [ __ ]
about like there'll be maybe 12 people
there yeah but this is the fight that
this is the after school fight that
everybody is going to be at yeah
um strikes new one yeah man i mean
people are gonna be there bro i'm gonna
be sick in this
i'm just sucking on my bag of milk and
showdown yeah um
do you do you think when you think back
to the first time you fought you were
i mean were you nervous going to that
one do you feel differently going into
the fight now
i i feel more confident in who i am i
know who i am now i know what i can take
i know
um the depths i might have to go the
uncomfortable
limit that might get reached in there
i'm okay and more
understanding of those things and and
accepting of them
but uh
yeah i just we got to get in there and
and and
and start moving around and and just i
want to get in there and feel the rhythm
and feel the
feel what's going on you know i'm
excited to to to get in there and
i don't know what's going to happen yeah
that's the thing you know and that but
that's why i'm so
uh i'm confident like i said in my
preparation
and the fighter i am i know i can trust
myself when it gets ugly in there
but um that's why i'm not scared to talk
about anything because there's no
it's true fighting is truth like i can't
go in there and and then pretend or fake
it in there you know what's gonna happen
is gonna happen i'm gonna win or i'm
gonna lose it's white and black there's
right
no gray area so i'm not scared to talk
about any of those aspects
about fights because there's nothing to
hide
you're going to see it january 23rd
you're going to spend the 60 bucks on
pay-per-view
and you're going to you're going to see
it so there's no reason to even try to
beat around the bush i'm prepared i'm
focused
i know i can beat anybody in the world i
feel like i'm one of the best at 155
pounds walking the earth
at this given time damn bro that sounds
almost egyptian when you say
i uh hieroglyphics
yeah and then that's just it man a lot
of the work has been done you've done a
lot of the work
yeah and i think a lot of times i was
fighting um
i was i was accomplishing things that
maybe my skill but that's tough to say
my skill level wasn't there yet but i
was
beating guys and rising up through the
ranks and
and getting myself in in big fights but
i was just learning on the job and i'm
still doing that you know i'm still
learning i'm gonna learn on the walk to
this one i've been learning all training
camp
this is a whole new journey i have to go
to abu dhabi i have to quarantine in
vegas
um you know i'm leaving this weekend
this is usually i'm still
sparring and still doing strength and
conditioning now i'm getting on flights
and quarantining so it's just a
different
landscape in 2020 or 2021 to go out and
put on one of the biggest events on
pay-per-view and fighting
and i'm just rolling with the punches
you know that and that's just it
but i'm confident in the work i put in
and like i said i know i can beat
anybody in the world
i just have to be mentally in the moment
that's what that's where this comes down
to i need to be in the moment to execute
you know execution is worshipped man and
i just need to be able to execute that
night
you know 25 minutes he can be better
than me the rest of the year i just need
25 minutes january 23rd that's not even
a half hour now that's dude
my daughter was conceived in less time
oh damn right hey i believe it
yeah so i've done some things myself but
yeah yeah
but that's just that's that's fighting
that's life that's where i'm at mentally
i feel like a lot of years
maybe my physical was here my minnow was
was catching up or
you know but i feel like it at next uh
in the next couple weeks i'll be 32
years old i feel like the physical in
the middle has finally started to align
and i'm
and i'm just at my prime right now yeah
yeah yeah well it's just been
interesting man even since you and i
become friends it it's just been
interesting
where you've just kind of gone as a
person you know it's just like we're
getting to those ages where you just
you kind of change a little bit you know
just kind of come into some
comfortability yeah in a more
uh like like i said accepting of who i
am i know who i am now
so i'm okay with the situations i'm in
right i don't know if that like in my
mind i don't feel overwhelmed or
uncomfortable i just feel like totally
i'm this i'm i'm supposed to be here
right i belong here
and it fits it does some of the other i
can totally relate it and stand up kind
of used to be times where i would go
like one time i had to get on the show
with bill burris about five years ago
maybe and i had to go before him on a
show and i'm like nervous i'm backstage
like
going over my jokes in my head like just
and i'm just nervous i'm thinking about
everything i'm gonna be doing with my
body
and then i go out there and i'm not even
really enjoying it i'm doing my job
and i'm doing it fine and it's in a big
stage but
i'm not really as present as i would
like to be because i'm still
in my mind getting comfortable with the
size of the
of the environment yeah and then now if
i were to go on stage beforehand you
know
with some of these guys i just not that
i'm still not honored and i'm still not
excited and everything but i just
i've been there the jacket feels like
okay i know what this jacket
feels like yeah same exact thing like
i've been there yeah i know this is a
different fight a different stage more
or more is on the line but i've been
here it's it's uh
i'm acquainted with this uncomfortable
feeling and i kind of know what to
expect
and as i'm getting older more mature and
i'm like i said i still feel young i
have another five years of fighting
[ __ ] yeah yeah ten years yeah i uh you
know i feel great but i know every time
i make that walk
is is one less time that i'm gonna be
able to make that walk so i'm enjoying
it more
yeah you know when i was young and just
fighting and trying to get the
the win and trying to get the checks and
trying to get sponsors and just going
crazy
in a rush oh yeah you know monster
energy all night in a whirlwind of just
like
caring about everything now i'm just
caring about the the
art of it and the process of the fight
i'm enjoying that that more
native is aluminum free deodorant
and it's a great addition to your 2021
routine
native cares about what you put in your
armpits
native cat i will repeat that native
cares about what you put in your armpit
none of their products are tested on
animals and everything is vegan
and i've been damned if i've ever seen
an animal wearing a deodorant anyway
even though i think i haven't seen a
raccoon put on deodorant
because you know how they are always in
there you know eating an old chunk of
cabbage or
doing a little lip gloss you can choose
from over 10 cents
including their classics and rotating
seasonal smell seasonal
why smell the same in january as you do
in september
make the switch to native today by going
to native
deo.com theo
or use promo code theo at checkout and
get 20
off your first order that's n a t i v
e d e o dot com
theo or use promo code theo at checkout
for 20
off your first order do you have a hard
time taking pills
do you have a hard time staying hard
well
solve it all with blue chew
get the only sildenaful and tata lawful
chewables by visiting bluechew.com
if you like doing sex or if you like
masturbating yourself and touching
yourself when you're hard
they can help you and they're good
people are there that do it blue chew
offers men and performance enhancement
for the bedroom you get the first
chewables with the active ingredients
sildenaful or tadalafo
bluechu.com their affiliated physicians
work with you to find the dosage an
active ingredient that is best for you
but we're talking
bluechew.com made in the usa
here's a great deal for you guys visit
bluechew.com and get your first order
free
when you use promo code theo just pay
five dollars shipping that's b l u e
c h e w dot com promo code theo
enjoy that hardness
you've all i mean you've become this
good vibe you got this whole good vibe
tribe going with you now like
every time i see your instagram you're
just feeling good you're living like
it's almost like you're like jimmy
buffett steps on or something you know
like
you're just having a good time you know
like yeah it seems like you're loving
life you know what do you think
is some of the stuff that's going on and
maybe some stuff you've been talking
about
yeah i'm just happier with with
reality i guess i don't know what you
can say but i'd be lying if i sat up
here and said um i don't have bad days
you know we all have bad days but i felt
like in the last couple years i've been
able to
get more use of slapping myself back in
shape you know and just and seeing the
better things
just staying in a place of gratitude
like we've spoke before about i feel
like it's easier for me to do that
because i have so much to be thankful
for and grateful for
and uh i'm happy about those things you
know yeah just gotta
if i do have those days where i'm kind
of down or overworked or
i just you know i get to do this i don't
have to and i'm happy
that i'm in a position to do it and and
like you said with the foundation
and stuff like that i have so much good
things and and so much
positivity on my back that i'm carrying
that i just use that as momentum
in every day i feel i just feel good man
i'm happy with the guy i look at in the
mirror
and i think that's most important it's
inspiring man i mean you've definitely
honestly really inspired me over the
years man i appreciate that
that that means a lot to me man and it's
and i'm not trying to you know so thank
you that means even more yeah that's
what i think
people say i'm just i'm just a man yeah
not the man not he-man yeah and
and i'm happy with the guy and i'm just
trying to do good stuff man and fight
good fights and work as hard as i can
and put my family in a good position and
it's [ __ ] an incredible ride that's
all we can all do man yeah right
um but i think yeah i think that's what
some of the inspiration is it's like
you just see somebody doing kind of like
what we can all do
if we you know get up and stay focused
and apply ourselves i feel like that's
what the vibe that i get thank you man
um you did you and did you lose your
first ufc fight wasn't you didn't win
i won my first ufc you did yeah it was
actually just made 10 years ago the
other day
was my some fight i was looking at i was
just looking through all your fights and
it was one it was like
for some reason on the chart they have
it maybe my first fight in the wec
i don't remember because i was just
going to ask you was it tough to have
that first experience where it felt like
you didn't get
the first loss of my professional career
was uh in las vegas in the wec
and ufc or zuffa owned the wc they
eventually absorbed all the fighters and
moved them over to the ufc
but it was like it was a decision i
think yeah i lost a decision
in my first professional loss was that
pretty spooked was it like after do you
feel like after that did you feel like
kind of like
what kind of happened dude every loss is
heartbreaking but that one hurt me
financially because like i was fighting
on the local scene
hey you need those bucks bro yeah i
thought oh [ __ ] i'm going to vegas i'm
fighting on tv i'm about to really make
it
and then your coroner's flights get
deducted and your medicals get deducted
and
this and that gets deducted and you lose
the fight and then you're like damn i
was making more fighting in
10 minutes from my house yeah and i have
a
i just bought a house me and my wife we
were 19 years old we bought our first
house so i had a mortgage
you know i had grown man bills man dude
i was uh
keeping my head above water i was riding
a bicycle to work and stuff damn
but that the financial part of that i
mean the loss obviously broke
broke my heart and it hurt um but the
financial part i thought i finally made
it
i'm in the wc i'm signing i'm going to
las vegas the fight oh i bet
you show up yeah take that l home with
you
yeah did they give you a special box to
put the hell in nah man you had to carry
it
then they charged me on the plane to
bring it back it was spirit i flew
spirit
dog dude i'm no joke i saw two dogs
fight each other on a spirit airlines
flight bro about four months ago i was
flying somewhere spirit
and i knew they were beefing in the line
at checking i never flown spirit dude
it's basically like
it's like playing a video game it's kind
of like the city bus of the air yeah it
really is
yeah one guy got off one guy halfway
through the flight just got off it was
his stop
so that blew my mind but two people had
dogs bro and finally they let him go bro
and they finished it up dude the pilot
comes on and starts the betting odds
yeah yeah dude
one of them is fighting henry cejudo
soon i think actually yeah triple c
it was uh it was that it was definitely
it must have been on some sort of card
um michael chandler and uh dan hooker
might be on that card with you guys i
saw that dude that's a great fight
and uh uh a good test for chandler to
see where he's at in the pecking order
of the lightweight division because
he'll toss him in the top end
which he should be man you know he's one
of the best 150 fighters out there
he's definitely i mean it's a hard work
i mean he's you know he's done obviously
a wonderful and bellator
he's he's a really nice guy dude i've
met him
um he actually went out of his way to
come shake my hand he said that
introduce himself and i was like man
this is
it seems like a really straight shooter
a really good guy man he's a nice dude
and he works so hard uh i mean all you
guys do especially at your level i mean
it's your full-time job yeah what do you
think about that fight i mean you
haven't fought in chandler but you've
gotten a fight hooker
do you have any thoughts on that fight i
um it'll be
i think it'll come down to i think uh
hooker beats him on the feet
i i do and uh i think the length you
know chandler's not a tall guy
hooker's really long and and a better
boxer than i thought he was
good timing tough to get his rhythm
he's a hooker is a tough fight for
anybody i think it'll be if chandler can
get the takedowns
and if he does can he keep him down i
think it's it's going to be a 15 minute
fight if it's on the same card as us
so he might you know if he starts
getting takedowns and getting dominant
position he might be able to win a
decision
i'm not saying he can't finish hooker he
can finish him but
i would lean towards hooker on that one
man
yeah i don't know the odds i don't know
the odds but i would give hooker a
slight edge
just anna's chandler's first fight in
the ufc i'm sure he has a lot of
a lot on his back a lot to prove but i
think he's a good point but like you
said he's a veteran
he's been fighting big names and stuff
like that for a long time so he
might not even phase him you know um
what will your uh quarantine be like so
i leave here saturday mm-hmm
go to actually take a covet test
tomorrow morning
leave here saturday when i land in vegas
i take another test
i quarantine two days there after
quarantine
i get on a flight to abu dhabi we fly
from vegas to abu dhabi when i land
there i
i uh get tested again it's a nice flight
huh they're uh chartering
oh really yeah damn you going private uh
i'll be hungry i can't eat i'll be
cutting you know starting the weight
cuttings no way
yeah you can't be on a plane the whole
time you can't have a snack do a couple
almonds
you can't have nothing nothing i mean
we'll see almonds yeah really yeah oh
that's the thing
i might actually fast on the flight i
might do the uh here's the best if
you're going to middle east bro yeah get
some dates when i get off
oh yeah huh we'll see we'll see but land
in abu dhabi
take a test quarantine two days there
and then i'm free to to move around the
uh
hotel that ufc has bubbled off and the
training rooms and all the stuff they
have there i'm not sure what amenities
exactly they're going to have but
so everybody will be there uh will you
see
connor before the fight do you think is
there yeah i'm sure i'm sure really like
at the breakfast bar or something is it
is that is it that kind of vibe
because that seemed weird as hell yeah i
mean that's any fight any fight we
usually stay at the same
area we have press conferences before so
we run into each other before fights
dang yeah do you what do you feel like
that interaction will be like
i have no clue i mean we might but you
don't have any animal i mean you don't
have
no but uh i want to fight
yeah yeah yeah man no no anger or
animosity towards him i'm not gonna be a
dick and go like
go out of my way try to harass the guy
or get in his face i'm not really we're
fighting
right for money that saturday so there's
no reason to [ __ ] have whatever he's
gonna do it earlier yeah
there's no reason to freaking yeah be
fighting over a yogurt at the damn
breakfast yeah let's do it
let's make the money right yeah dang bro
how do you see the fight going out do
you play it out in your head kind of do
you
it must be so hard to wait for that
moment it's just like it is man it is
god it's like
if we're all waiting we're all like
jesus christ you know
yeah just over in your head the anxiety
is so high you know you're just like
the good thing is like once your music
starts playing and they they say your
name and you start walking then it's
over like you know
then you're just doing it there's no no
time to think then that's the and that's
the best part for me once once i start
walking and stuff then it's just it's go
time there's no
there's no thinking it's too late to to
think it's not react you know
some guys do too much on the walk-in you
know they do too much it is too much
they triple prey or something like some
of that's too much yeah they have a
dance routine
some of it's too much yeah i don't mind
a little for me anyway i'm just a
regular viewer but i don't mind a little
but sometimes it's too much you know
yeah maybe to the casual like uh filthy
casuals or whatever they call them yeah
whatever
whatever it is that that extra stuff
might be cool you know like
like some guy pulls a dove out under his
arm yeah yeah they got some wild
yeah dude yeah it's getting pretty
flammable
yeah you know a lot of the uh you know
connor's definitely a guy who's been you
know he has like the most flamboyance
you could have i mean he's the ric
flair almost yeah yeah he's like the
irish ric flair you know
uh and he does it super well yeah he is
i remember like
there was a time where you and i talked
a couple years ago and you're like
that's not really your thing
you know like trying to be that i
understand it but it's right
yes it's not your thing and i did you
feel like at
a point that maybe you wouldn't be able
to get to certain levels of
popularity because you didn't have that
but but now you've gotten there with
your own way
yeah i'll just keep gunning it out you
know keep working keep grinding
and and hopefully one day put myself in
a position to fight for the belt which i
have
i'm trying to do it again here but i'm
not going to go that route you know i
understand it i understand it's
entertainment
and stuff like that i just don't don't
like it man yeah yeah
it's a turn off for me even when i see
other guys do it i'm like oh [ __ ]
some of it's too much yeah some people
yeah they bring a little they gotta go
for
something on them they do something yeah
they're doing wow they could bring
voodoo dolls or whatever
yeah they don't there's no limits yeah
it's getting wild
do you feel like it's getting weirder
overall though or you feel like in the
end it's going to stay kind of where it
is
i think it's going to stay where it's at
i i think since kind of first
came on the scene i've seen a huge rise
in it you know like a lot of guys that
started trying to yeah sugar shawn's a
guy
he's the guy that likes the pomp and the
you know i've seen more of it since
conor became a superstar
you know but also you have to be able to
fight you can't just be
a joker out there getting your ass away
yeah yeah you can't go out there and
juggle a couple times and get your ass
beat yeah
yeah then you're at the like state fair
yeah
yeah yeah uh do you um
do you uh do you how do you see the
fight kind of playing out do you
envision that kind of thing like what do
you
yeah but it's just like so many ways it
could play out
he does those kicks early remember yeah
he throws a lot of
spin kicks wheel kicks he's a good
athlete man he's impressive
oh yeah it's almost like it's like uh
watching that cap aware that brazilian
dance kind of like he has a lot of that
in him
yeah he he does and he got says long
good comparison
um a little bit of unpredictability with
the spinning kicks and
and stuff like that in the shoulders and
and knees you know it's a it's a
no holds barred fight though so those
things are expected right you know
anything can happen
but i i really feel like i'm going to go
out there
and be more in tune with the flow in
there
touch him make him miss and i just i
just want the fight to blossom and i
want to see who's the better fighter
yeah and like i said i think we need to
be
i can suffer more i i we we need to be
damaging each other and we both need to
dig down
and i want it to be that kind of uh
performance i want it to be gritty i
want to leave a piece of myself in there
and i want him to do the same and i want
to see who gets our you know who who
comes out with their hand raised
i envision i miss a lot of different
things happening and and the fight going
different ways but at the end i always
envision
me winning you know getting back on that
long flight home
with the win come and see my daughter
that that feels so good you know and
whatever it takes to get to make that a
reality i'm willing to do so let's just
go
would you kill him i don't want to i
i mean i don't want to yeah i don't want
to kill anybody
yeah i feel you man yeah but that's not
that i'm not a that's not a goal
yeah that's not a goal okay i like that
i respect that bro
yeah yeah you don't want to be that guy
no i don't wish that on anybody yeah
you're right man i shouldn't even ask
that
um yeah you never know you know
but if years from now we find out that
you were a serial killer in lafayette
you know
people would be like i knew it bro he
had it in him you know yeah
i mean but i never admitted it yeah but
he never admitted it bro dude that'd be
so gangster if you were a freaking ufc
champion and a serial killer that's
crazy dude i'm watching that thing on a
unobama right now
that dude is [ __ ] weird man yeah yeah
did he seem interesting at all or no
yeah dude he lived in a shack out in the
woods and he was mailing bombs and
leaving
clues and stuff what a weirdo
yeah he took a [ __ ] in his neighbor's
bathtub and left him yeah
dude i'll tell you a good story so my
friend used to be a moving man like a
furniture guy you know
and he had to work for regis philbin one
time and move his furniture
and he said regis was so rude to him
that he ended up taking a crap in his
bathtub
and left it in there nice
he ever met any bombs i know he didn't
do any of that man
no he never really went to that next
level yeah he stayed on that
yeah yeah he's telling that servant that
yeah but that's a special place too
though that is probably
a special place dude what if you ever
say one day you retire years down the
road 15
25 years down the road uh we should do
like some fight campaign or something
that'd be fun huh if i learned enough
about fighting i'd have to learn a lot
more
yeah you kind of inspired me i was like
man maybe i should do a
talk about fighting podcasts or
something like that but then i just
thought about
all the other stuff i have going on and
man i just i don't know if i can have
time to do it you could do it later yeah
yeah you got a lot going because i would
love to talk about fights you know yeah
i really would yeah
do you feel like that now do you feel
like you kind of uh
because i remember we talked in the past
maybe about a school or something you're
like i don't know if i would really want
to do that
do you have any different thoughts on it
now but you're still like in it though
yeah and i just signed a new eight-fight
contract with ufc my plan
my plan is to fight fight eight more
times you know i want to finish this
this contract i'm on eight fights
fight eight more times and we'll see
where we're at there but i'm not looking
past that or
before that i'm going to fight eight
more times that's crazy dude i don't
know if the world can handle it more
dude i don't know if my brain can't
they're good
yeah yeah dude that last one was a rough
one man that was a while yeah yeah
i remember yeah you came back after oh
yeah [ __ ] you were there bro thanks for
coming out yeah
no worries yeah that was awesome that
was exciting and then you wanted to sit
and then we sat and watched the fight
dude that was so cool
that was awesome that was really awesome
had a good group there that was a good
group dude what are you guys doing for
uh
what were you what will people in
lafayette be doing for the fight
i'm not sure i know some people are
going to bars um is there anything big
plant is good fight doing anything we
were thinking about trying to get a
restaurant
like we did uh for this last fight we
just haven't locked anything down yet
we we just uh put together a big thing
with the boys and girls club
of acadiana oh really yeah we're doing a
big thing with them actually um
next year well this year 2021 we're
doing uh tutors for all of their six
locations
oh wow for the year because you know
social distancing and the learning
kids at home you know it's it's been a
mess so we're going to help them get
tutors to
to the children's homes and also
transportation to and from the boys and
girls clubs for the year for the kids oh
gang
yeah yeah so i'm pumped about that the
good fight foundation is doing that and
then
connor's donating some money to the good
fight foundation and we're going to open
up a gym
in lafayette for really for the children
yeah yeah
yeah dude that's awesome so it's just
for kids or is it for white belts also
they're adults
we're going to do better near 40. nah
we're gonna do kids
like uh in school but i have a gym there
dude you're always welcome in my gym
dude you have beginners classes
uh no but my buddies jim does oh he does
yeah yeah yeah
my gym is kind of like just a private
gym we just do pro training there
but my buddy has a beginner jiu jitsu
classes and stuff dude i'd love to jump
in one if you if you're back in time
dude that'd be awesome yeah
i'll put the key back on would you
rather maybe it's been a while i haven't
put a gear on in a while
so you so so you the training that you
do is different than
like the classes and stuff you're just
you're training with fighters
yeah mostly some sometimes i'm working
just with just two instructors if we're
working on things
but uh beginning of my career even as a
pro beginning my pro career i would do a
lot of ghee
and stuff because i was in louisiana and
didn't have
as much classes to choose from i didn't
have as many pro fighters around me so
i would substitute training sessions in
regular classes because that's all i had
you know i had to learn
oh you see four kids fighting in a
remedial reading class in [ __ ]
vermillion paris
yeah and then i'd ask them to drill that
how do you do that again that's how i
learned
yeah some guy is beating the vowels into
somebody yeah yeah
getting ar reader points and stuff yeah
but uh yeah but it's been a while since
i've done a
just like a gi jiu jitsu class oh yeah
man i've been choked out so many times
last month
um it's awesome yeah it's got it it's
fun man
right dude it's so much fun i never knew
how like
i leave out of there dude and i [ __ ]
hope a cop pulls me over
yeah you know yeah because i know it's
going to [ __ ]
be me or him one of us got to go yeah
yeah
i just leave out of there feeling
[ __ ] different dog you know yeah like
the guy when i get to the gas station he
[ __ ] knows i'm using my
he knows i'm paying card and he knows
i'm in and out yeah yeah
everybody i just feel like you start to
get a different little bit of confidence
you get a different family too because
it's like you know you don't realize how
big the subculture of jiu jitsu is
unless you're in into it but like you
start training and you get friends and
stuff at the gym and then you start
going to competitions or talking about
jujitsu with them and then you go to
barbecues and then you're like [ __ ] this
is my friends now yeah a whole new set
of family really at the gym
that's what happened to me yeah yeah i
was like damn like these are my these
are my family and friends now you know
just from training with them
yeah yeah dude i go to this restaurant
and i go in there and two of the guys
from the uh
mma class in nashville are both work
there one of them
does the oysters this guy on hell dude
he's [ __ ] kimoro kamor and these
oysters
back there dude he's [ __ ] got a crab
leg and he's got it in a [ __ ]
i need some moisture marcellus choke you
know yeah [ __ ] interesting
yeah but um yeah and one thing i noticed
like just my confidence like
i've only been like maybe 15 classes so
i'm let's don't get you know
don't anybody come at me but um
but i noticed just like i used to feel
like if i got in a fight somebody was
gonna beat me up but i would also be
scared at the same time
now i just feel like somebody's gonna
beat me up
right i don't feel like i'm also gonna
be scared yeah that's and that's good
that's growth so it's yeah it's just
crazy i never i always like oh [ __ ] dude
because it would suck to get beat up and
be being scared at the same time yeah
yeah and then the longer you do it the
next step i think is everything starts
to look like a lapel
like really well this guy's shirt he
wore a [ __ ] jacket today
cross-choke you with that yeah
everything starts to look like a lapel
oh this guy's got long eyelashes
i'm gonna choke this guy with his
mustache oh yeah
everything is a weapon um who is
who gets to go with you so you will mike
brown and those guys go with you this
time
yeah so um my boxing coach and
kickboxing coach are gonna stay behind
and catch the next charter
mike brown is going to come with me to
vegas and come with me to abu dhabi
and uh the rest of my team and my wife
will get there
i think four days after after i get
there so
it's good they'll go through their
two-day quarantine when they land and
then we'll all be able to
start training and stuff but i'll be out
there 13 days before the fight so i
think that'll be
enough because we're also fighting early
morning abu dhabi time
so at first i thought i need to get out
there to get adjusted to the time
um but the the cards going live
normal pay-per-view time here so 10
eastern the pay-per-view goes live wow
but it'll be
whatever it is eight or nine a.m what a
night of fights it's gonna be the
biggest fight since trump biden i think
yeah probably yeah yeah it'll be up
there or since
cove at moderna since that new vaccine
came out look it's a new year and it's
uh it's
you know it's it's time for us to start
thinking about our bodies and our
self-care
and sometimes it's hard these days
because we're going fast we're on the
move that's why beach body on demand
offers over
1500 at-home workouts plus nutrition
plans
so no matter what your goals are they
got that program that will help you
build and keep healthy habits that's
where it starts
this is the company behind p90x insanity
and 21 day fix now check out some of
beachbody's newest programs
muscle burns fat and 80 day obsession
millions of people have gotten well and
gotten healthy and created
good habits you can be one of them to
get a special free trial
no obligation membership text t-h-e-o
to thirty thirty thirty you'll get full
access to the entire platform
all the workouts nutritional information
get them eaters
just text t-h-e-o to thirty thirty
thirty that's the number three zero
three zero three zero
look start a program get in shape take
care of yourself you feel
good when you do good and i believe that
you can do it
today's episode is also brought to you
by athletic greens they've basically
taken all the
the time it takes in the wear and tear
on your neck to eat a
big salad in the old days you got to eat
40 carrots you got to eat nine celeries
those are over i get my athletic greens
i get a water pour the athletic greens
in
put an ice cube in mix it up
and i'm good as gold baby
simply visit athleticgreens.com t-h-e-o
and join health experts athletes and
health conscious go-getters around the
world
who make daily commitments to their
every
day health again simply visit
athleticgreens.com
you'll get a free year supply of vitamin
d
and five free travel packs today that's
right
they're offering our audience free one
year supply of vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase
many of the population of vitamin d
deficient doesn't have to be you visit
athleticgreens.com
theo and get your free year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
today
so what will you do to like adjust like
your sleep patterns and stuff will you
like
you what did you learn last time that
you went there see last time we fought
on
uae time so this is completely different
ah i see what you're saying so you're
fighting on the u.s time fight on u.s
time last time we fought
uae russia time but is that going to be
weird you wake up in the morning and
then you go fight
[ __ ] punches and pancakes yeah yeah
yeah now that's what you should throw in
lafayette punches and pants
and pancakes yeah but it'll be normal
time in life yeah sure yeah
damn [ __ ] we should not come up
we just keep spitballing here yeah yeah
something'll stick you know yeah
something will stick
yeah um but i'm gonna um start doing
some late night runs
like around uh because you have a plan
right 12 easter and i'll start doing
some some sweats
keep it up when i go out to vegas and
then hopefully when i land there i'm
landing there in the morning so i'm
gonna just get off the plane and start
my day
try to go to sleep a little early and
wake up earlier so i'm gonna try to get
up around like
6 7 a.m abu dhabi time when i land out
there
just to give me a couple hours before
i'll be fighting connor you know
you don't be young yeah you're someone
beyond and that's a bad look yeah yeah
and mike bryan then will be able to go
yeah oh that's awesome man so everybody
will be there
dude that's freaking dude honestly and
and it's exciting because it's a new
journey for me with all this quarantine
and
the hustle of traveling to different
locations just to get to the fight
so i'm excited man let's start the
journey yeah like i don't know what's
gonna [ __ ] happen but let's go
yeah it's gonna be fun i mean to think
that i know i'm gonna fight i know that
part's gonna happen right but all the
other stuff is like exciting
the weight cut and and you know not i
can't bring my nutritionist with me i
usually have a team of nutritionists who
cook the meals and do all this stuff for
me
so i don't [ __ ] know damn bro but
when will you be able to start eating
again oh after the weigh-in
after the week so how long is that
weight cut time i mean i'm starting
kind of starting my weight cut now
getting getting you know i've been
dieting for the last eight weeks
hardcore i think i came out here at like
182 pounds maybe
yeah and then i'll be on january 23rd or
january 22nd i'll be 155.
so you have to lose like 15 percent of
your body
there's a math thing again yeah that's
true and i and that was definitely that
was a guess yeah yeah
but you have it's like imagine if
somebody said cut your arm up and put
your arm somewhere
that's crazy yeah you know
yeah it's i mean it's like it's a good
bit of a good bit of weight
155 is getting tough for me to make now
man yeah yeah could this be your last
fight at 155
i definitely believe i'm gonna fight at
170 i don't know how many times in the
ufc i fought at 170 before in my career
before but uh never in the ufc but i
think i'm going to fight one stephanie
before
you know this eight fights run out i'm
gonna i'm gonna fight somebody
welterweight
i'm just glad you and i get to have a
good conversation before you go through
eight more fights
yeah and subtitles we're having to write
stuff on a board
yeah and put it back and forth between
each other
um and the gym that we're at right now
is this is for
weight training for strength and
conditioning strength and conditioning
yeah okay
yeah and this is happening how did you
get in in touch with these guys
so me and phil um daru strong
that's his strength strength condition
facility here they gave me this shirt
and they
trained me earlier yeah good guy i'm
sure you'll be sore yeah
i've been working with him for a lot of
fights now and and uh
he moved into this new location and i
just came with him he was at american
top team then he was at a place in
pompano beach
um he has his place in port st lucie as
well he has a big gym there i believe
and uh and now he has a branch of it
here and this is the one i come to
what if is there is there a type of gym
you walk into or like all this ain't
from me like it has
like what what does a gym need to have
that you like
oh i don't really like like the meat
head
if you're talking about weightlifting
gems or strengthening conditions yeah
really like the meat head
persona like tough guy stuff i just like
to work and be efficient and
try to get better stronger we have like
a goal you know not just lift heavy [ __ ]
and make noise
right if we have a goal we're working
towards a goal that's that's what i want
like that alvin kamara vibe kind of
yeah six touchdowns i know that's crazy
you could've had seven
yeah six touchdown but if you you get co
if you apparently if you get six
times you get covered that's what they
said yeah yeah
but i mean that's a good trade-off oh
yeah take it
i mean only one other person has got six
touchdowns a lot of people recover from
kova
yeah that's true yeah but a lot of
people have died as well i mean it's
tough
yeah i take i take my chance though yeah
i'd go i'd go in for six if they gave if
they're like hey there's covet in there
but i'm like i'm going back in yeah
you're diving in yeah yeah
um do you worry that covet is a good
excuse to get out of a fight if somebody
wants to do you think that connor's the
type of guy that would cove it out
nah no way he's a real fighter he's a
real fighter yeah he
he won't no no way but i don't know how
you get how would you get going
i think you you could just i think find
a way to contract you know just to get
it
like i just it's it's like a weird time
in history where you can kind of get
something to get out of work you can get
it to
get out of things it's like people have
a way out i mean you know if they're
healthy they're probably going to be
fine so it's like
dude i've been trying my best honestly
besides going to that hotel
i go to the grocery store and that's
into the gym and that's it
really try yeah yeah you like even when
i'm running outside and somebody's on
the sidewalk i'll go in the street
they don't run around them yeah i'm just
trying not to breathe that
oh damn well i got tested a couple of
weeks ago anyway yeah
i'm getting tested tomorrow morning damn
yeah zoom on a zoom call
really they're testing over zoom now
yeah i have what do they do if you have
it
i have i have a package and uh oh my god
i got it i got to do it on
on really yeah i gotta open it in front
of them and send it right off
wow that's crazy man they just guess if
you have it because cleo's actually on
the other
side put the stick in your nose darling
um tell us okay so before you go man uh
dude i love the new hot sauce and i'll
be honest i did not think i was gonna
like it just because
everybody sells stuff now right and i
got it swipe up save ten percent
yes yep and um dude what i find is
because i make basic meals at home i get
turkey meat and get some
spinach mix it together douse it with
the pouriers bruh
it is good dude it's a perfect sauce for
me because it's a
it's hot but it's not it doesn't like
burn you out at all yeah
yeah it's not too heavy it can if you
eat a bunch
back-to-back bites of just sauce on
something it'll get a little hot but
it's not bad at all i uh
the the flavor is what i'm happy with
and proud of man the flavor is
really good bro like if i'm doing eggs
if i'm doing anything i'm like oh it's a
perfect sauce man
yeah i'm proud of it man and uh i want
to keep going you know i want to i want
to do more things i want to have a
louisiana barbecue sauce a couple other
things right
you know because you like on that same
right i love to cook i love to cook
yeah people don't know that man i love
to cook dude i want to cook it i want a
cooking show man
i'd let you go six or seven rounds with
a brisket right oh dude i can throw down
oh yeah dude i love that um i can throw
down with the brisket i got the smoker
at the house
oh i'd love to see you beat the [ __ ] out
of a [ __ ] bag of shrimp dude no
problem
dude we're so excited for you man we're
going to make a thousand dollar donation
to the good fight foundation
and incredible dude that's going
straight towards uh boys and girls club
so thank you dude that's
awesome man and uh and just thank you so
much for spending time with us here
today man always cool bro
thank you for helping uh for for getting
phil to help me get a workout in and
and um yeah dude this we just wish you
luck man we'll be cheering you on
brother
thanks man godspeed three weeks it goes
down it's crazy huh
let's go i can't [ __ ] wait let's go
ain't nothing to it but to do it
amen man now i'm just floating on the
breeze and i feel i'm falling
like these leaves i must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel it in my bones
but it's gonna take a little
time for me to set that parking brake
and let myself on my heart
shine that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load
[Music]
they're gone